mayor bill de blasio of new york is a
nostalgic man
loves the 70s he's turned his city into
a version of new york in the 70s and
just
as it was 50 years ago one of the most
dangerous places to be in new york
is in its world famous subway system
last year more than a dozen people were
shoved
onto the subway tracks many by the
so-called homeless that the city's
elites tolerate for reasons they never
explained
this year new york city is on pace to
exceed that number of people pushed in
front of moving subway
cars just this morning the violence on
the subway progressed from
indiscriminate shoving to indiscriminate
stabbing
according to the nypd five new york city
subway riders were attacked in 35
minutes
in manhattan today all in the same
subway line it began around 4 25 am
one of the victims was a 41 year old man
he said someone woke him up on the
subway and punched him in the face
just minutes later somebody else stabbed
a 44 year old man in the head on the
same train
then a 44 year old man was stabbed in
the right eye police have arrested
four people in those stabbings new york
city's metropolitan transit authority
issued a statement blaming quote
the mayor's negligence on this issue
these were five
very serious armed robbery and slashing
incidents at stations on the same line
all seemingly could have been prevented
by a uniform presence on each of these
platforms end quote but that would be
insensitive to the
vagrants now ruling public
transportation in new york hey sean
hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else